Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
magazine historia vous présente il était
une loi quand le Sénat écrit l'histoire
[Musique]
le gouvernement de la République
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la mort c'est pas un problème d'expert
et c'est pas un problème de médecin
c'est pas un problème de politique la
mort ça nous concerne tous alors comment
faire pour quitter la vie de la dignité
ce jeter du dixième étage pour d'un
fusil se faire sauter la tête se pendre
quand la famille rentre le soir toute
vie mérite d'être vécue c'est ça en fait
la grande question je pensais qu'il
fallait aller sur cette question
d'aide active à mourir c'est pas normal
aujourd'hui qui est plus de 150 000
Français qui ne puissent pas avoir accès
aux soins palliatifs à mourir c'est pas
juste oui ou non en fait c'est on peut
être contre et en même temps un certain
moment se dire que ben on est contre
mais il y a des situations qui sont
intolérables on peut être pour mais se
dire qu'on peut être pour à certaines
conditions bien précises
c'est une bataille parlementaire
annulent l'autre pareil voilà près de 20
ans que la France légifère sur la fin de
vie sans jamais parvenir tout à fait à
régler le problème il faut dire que la
question est plus délicate parce qu'elle
touche chacun d'entre nous dans ce que
nous avons de plus intime et personne ne
nous interroge collectivement sur la
façon dont nous appréhendons la fin de
l'existence dans notre société comment
soulager ou abréger les souffrances d'un
malade aux portes de la mort faut-il le
laisser mourir faut-il l'aider à mourir
faut-il le faire mourir autant
d'interrogation ou semelles des
considérations médicales juridiques
éthiques mais aussi philosophique et
même souvent religieuse autant de débats
qui ont pu émouvoir rassembler ou
diviser à l'Assemblée nationale comme
ici au Sénat en 2005 puis en 2016 et
peut-être bientôt une nouvelle fois
encore qui sait c'est au parlementaire
qu'on a demandé de trancher en leur
ramait conscience davantage qu'en
fonction de clivage partisans auxquels
nous sommes habitués
comment la classe politique s'est-elle
déjà emparée par deux fois du sujet de
la fin de vie pour tenter de faire
avancer le droit des malades et répondre
aux attentes de la société pourquoi nos
élus ont-ils autant de réticences à
parler d'euthanasie ou de suicides
assistés et pourquoi selon combat est-il
encore loin d'être terminé c'est
l'histoire que nous allons vous raconter
[Musique]
bonjour Sandrine manchard bonjour vous
êtes journaliste au Monde et si je
tenais à commencer cette émission avec
vous c'est parce que vous avez couvert
pour votre journal l'histoire d'un jeune
homme qui a ému la France et qui a porté
sur le devant de la scène se débat sur
sur la fin de vie ce jeune homme il
s'appelle Vincent Imbert qui est Vincent
Imbert Vincent Imbert c'est un jeune
garçon enfin un jeune homme de 19 ans
normand qui est pompier bénévole et qui
va être victime d'un terrible accident
de voiture et il va se retrouver
tétraplégique
muet aveugle
et il n'aura il ne lui restera pour lui
que sa tête parce que sa tête fonctionne
et Louis il entend et donc quand il se
réveille après 9 mois de coma il est
dans l'état que vous décrivez mais on
s'aperçoit qu'il a toute sa tête parce
qu'il va parvenir à communiquer avec sa
maman notamment oui va être à son chevet
quotidiennement et va essayer de le
ramener à la vie en lui faisant écouter
de la musique en communiquant etc et va
arriver le moment où il peut bouger
bouger les mains bouger les doigts et il
va trouver un système elle va lui
faire l'alphabet
et lui dire quand tu veux me dire
quelque chose et quand la phrase
commence par un a ou un B et je te
donnerai l'alphabet et tu sers à ma main
pour me dire que c'est la bonne lettre
et c'est comme ça qui vont arriver à
communiquer
j'étais en contact avec avec sa mère et
à un moment donné je demande à sa mère
je dis écoutez est-ce que je pourrais
rencontrer votre fils
et elle me elle me dit d'accord et je
suis arrivé dans cette chambre et
c'était enfin c'était bouleversant
c'était vraiment même maintenant 20 ans
après quand j'y repense je ça m'émeut
encore parce que c'était la chambre d'un
jeune homme des Corée avec ses chanteurs
préférés les photos de sa famille etc et
qui était sur son lit recroquevillé avec
des coquilles sur les yeux
qui pouvaient rien faire de son corps
qui était qui était condamné à
l'immobilité qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit
il voulait mourir il ne pouvait pas
mettre fin à sa vie qui voudrait d'une
vie comme celle qu'il avait il se savait
condamner on savait par les médecins que
son cas n'y aurait pas d'amélioration il
y a potentiellement il peut vivre encore
20 ans dans cet état là parce que son
corps est jeune donc ça n'a aucun sens
pour lui et puis il va prendre une
décision sans en parler à sa mère
d'ailleurs il va décider d'écrire au
président de la République de l'époque
Jacques Chirac
bah oui c'est ça qui a fait
qui a fait éclaté au grand jour c'est
cette histoire et qu'il a qu'il a mis
dans le dans le débat public et face au
public quoi c'était une lettre avec
cette demande du droit à mourir du droit
à mourir il dit au président vous avez
le droit de grâce je vous demande le
droit de mourir le droit de mourir et
Jacques Chirac a reçu sa mère a pris en
considération ce courrier mais toujours
en disant je ne peux pas accéder à votre
demande et donc il reste une solution et
il va l'écrire dans un livre qu'il
publiera de façon posthume je veux que
l'on mette fin à mes jours et c'est
Maman qui va le faire maman puisque tu
m'aimes c'est toi qui va me tuer il faut
que tu fasses cela pour moi comment
réagit Marien Bert
c'est forcément extrêmement difficile
pour une pour une mère d'être face à
ces cornélien enfin c'est vraiment c'est
il y a rien de pire comme comme demande
mais il dit ce sera un acte d'amour de
ta part et tu m'aides à faire quelque
chose que je veux faire mais que je suis
dans l'incapacité physique de faire en
lui disant maman ce sera un acte d'amour
elle ça la tient ça la tient pour son
Titi comme elle disait donc elle va
passer à l'acte plus d'un an qui me
parle de la mort qui me
qui parle de la mort je me rappelle un
soir je lui dis ben comme tous les soirs
bonsoir mon titi à demain je t'aime
enfin bon bisous bisous enfin etc et qui
m'a repris la main en me disant mais
arrête maman tu m'aimes pas si tu
m'aimais tu me laisserais mourir le 24
septembre 2003 en fin d'après-midi elle
se retrouve seule dans sa chambre avec
Vincent Imbert et elle va lui injecter
une dose de Pinteaux barbitage de sodium
dans le tuyau qui le nourrit
et
l'équipe médicale va s'en apercevoir il
y a un infirmier qui va passer et qui va
donner l'alerte et donc Vincent Imbert
va être envoyé en réanimation c'est très
animation elle est dirigée par un homme
il s'appelle Frédéric Chaussoy docteur
Frédéric Chochois qui va être un
personnage quelqu'un de capital dans
cette histoire devant les caméras le
chef du service réanimation le docteur
Frédéric Chaussoy va annoncer à la
presse la décision collégiale qu'il a
prise avec son équipe on écoute
contenu de tableaux clinique de
l'évolution et des souhaits qu'avaient
exprimé les différentes reprises Vincent
et a décidé de limiter les
thérapeutiques actives l'équipe médicale
qu'il a accompagné pendant 3 ans a pris
cette décision
collective et difficile en toute
indépendant donc il ne cache rien et lui
aussi comme en fait comme la mère va
passer à l'acte c'est-à-dire injecter du
chlore de potassium débranche et
débrancher leur respirateur artificiel
deux informations judiciaires vont être
ouvertes une contre la mère de Vincent
Imbert et une contre le docteur Frédéric
chouxois oui parce qu'ils ont un frein à
la loi pour le coup avec les injections
qu'ils ont fait tous les deux il y a une
volonté de donner la mort bénéficieront
d'un non-lieu d'un non-lieu deux ans
plus tard comme très souvent dans ses
affaires les Français sont sensibles au
gestes de Marie Imbert toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion montrent que la le
public enfin société et majoritairement
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut faire
progresser la loi faire avancer la loi
vers une possibilité d'aide active à
mourir dans des situations bien
évidemment bien encadrées etc le
problème c'est qu'à l'époque la classe
politique ne veut pas en entendre parler
Jean-Pierre Raffin qui est premier
ministre accorde un entretien au Figaro
dans lequel il se refuse de légiférer
sur l'euthanasie dit on ne peut pas
gouverner ou légiférer pour des
situations spécifiques et puis lâche
cette petite phrase en forme de fin de
non recevoir la vie n'appartient pas à
la politique mais aujourd'hui
face au drame d'une maman face au drame
d'une famille je demande à tous qu'on
exprime les plus grandes réserves et
qu'on respecte le silence que l'on doit
à cette famille dans la douleur c'est
pas la question de légiférer pour des
cas particuliers c'est la question de se
dire est-ce qu'on peut faire avancer la
loi pour que dans certaines situations
on accepte d'aider
non pas de laisser mourir mais d'aider
d'aider à mourir quand il n'y a plus
aucun espoir d'amélioration quand il y a
une demande réitérer du patient qu'il a
sa conscience pour le faire etc etc
comment ne pas aboutir à ce choix là et
pourquoi ne pas accéder au choix de ce
jeune
moi je voilà il y a des choses qui
m'échappent là
sur le fait de se dire mais si toute vie
toute vie mérite d'être vécue c'est ça
en fait la grande question à l'automne
2003 le drame de Vincent Humbert va
émouvoir la France entière il s'invite à
la lune des journaux et suscite un débat
sur la fin de vie dans toute la société
il va même réunir deux députés de bord
opposés qui choisissent de joindre leur
force pour porter ce combat à
l'Assemblée tous deux ont vécu des
situations familiales particulièrement
douloureuses le premier le député
socialiste de la Nièvre gaétanque a été
très marqué par son impuissance à
soulager les dernières souffrances de
son père quant au père de la seconde la
députée de Meurthe-et-Moselle Nadine
Morano il a été victime d'un grave
accident vasculaire cérébral qu'il a
laissé lourdement handicapé furieux de
voir que le gouvernement refuse de se
saisir du problème c'est deux députés
convoquent la presse et réclament la
création d'une commission d'enquête et
leur voix va porter une mission
d'information parlementaire regroupant
une trentaine de membres toutes
tendances confondues est créée sa
présidence est confiée un député UMP des
Alpes-Maritimes cardiologue de
profession Jean Leonetti
Jean-Louis Debré a créé la surprise en
acceptant de mettre sur les rails une
mission d'information sur l'euthanasie
d'autant plus que ces derniers jours sur
ce dossier délicat le Premier ministre
insistait davantage sur l'intime que sur
le débat
bonjour Jean Leonetti bonjour vous êtes
mère d'anti vous avez été député des
Alpes-Maritimes pendant 20 ans et on
vous doit non pas une mais deux lois sur
la fin de vie à dix années d'intervalle
on y reviendra tout au long de cette
émission à l'automne 2003 c'est à vous
que revient la lourde de charge de
présider cette mission parlementaire sur
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
comment vous aviez vécu ou perçu cette
année vous je me suis senti très mal à
l'aise une mère qui donne la mort à son
fils son fils qui interpelle
le président de la République avant de
mourir un livre qui sort au moment où la
mort est donnée il y avait une mise en
scène tragique et
qui était extrêmement choquante ensuite
un médecin
en difficulté
qui d'abord réanime puis ensuite arrête
la réanimation et laisse venir la mort
et même la compagne
c'était il y avait tous les ingrédients
de la polémique et de la violence quel
était exactement votre feuille de route
à l'époque il y avait aucune perspective
de législation et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'à cette époque-là
Jean-Pierre Raffarin était pas
volontaire pour que il y a un texte de
loi
c'est des choses se sont fait en
cheminant alors comment avez-vous
travaillé prenez une trentaine de
parlementaires
il y a quelque chose qui apparaît très
très vite c'est qu'il y a des clivages
très forts pas forcément entre la droite
et la gauche d'ailleurs ce qui
m'apparaît à ce moment-là le plus
clivant c'est le vécu de la mort de
chaque député les gens disaient moi mon
père il est mort en hurlant de douleur
et il faut faire quelque chose et
éventuellement il aurait il aurait mieux
valu qui meurt quelques heures avant ou
quelques jours avant et donc le thanazi
est une solution et puis d'autres
disaient non moi les médecins ils savent
ce qu'ils doivent faire la grand-mère il
aura accompagné elle s'est endormie et
puis elle s'est pas réveillé pourquoi
faire une loi mais on sentait bien
quelle expérience de du tragique et de
la violence de la mort de celui qu'on
aime était avait imprimé une certaine
idée de ma propre mort puisque je pense
à ma mort en voyant la mort de celui que
j'aime et cette projection faisait que
il y avait des orientations qui étaient
différentes et vous même
moi je croyais connaître la mort parce
que je l'avais beaucoup rencontré
je suis réanimateur je suis le
cardiologue donc j'ai malheureusement
rencontré beaucoup de vie perdue et puis
mon métier était d'essayer que la mort
devienne pas voilà et qu'on la retarde
et qu'on la repousse et ce que cette
mission nous a appris à tous c'est au
fond on est sortis de nos certitudes
individuelles
et Dieu sait si j'en avais
pour rentrer dans un doute collectif on
a écouté des sociologues qui nous ont
dit attention vous croyez que la mort
c'est individuelle la mort c'est un fait
de société vous aviez écouté aussi des
historiens des philosophes des soignants
des soignants des soignants des des
soignants des pédiatres on a écouté des
les grandes religions monothéistes et
après chaque audition comment on dit
maintenant en débriefé c'est-à-dire en
disait alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
tu en as tiré toi et au fond
nos clivages se sont estompés voilà je
me rappelle de
d'échanges qui était d'une totale
liberté
et à avec des gens qui dans l'hémicycle
sont à l'opposé parce que finalement la
mort c'est pas un problème d'expert et
c'est pas un problème de médecin c'est
pas un problème de politique la mort ça
nous concerne tous quand est apparu
l'idée qu'il fallait faire évoluer la
législation dans votre groupe
alors peut-être j'étais trop obéissant à
cette époque là mais ça m'est pas venu à
l'idée du tout moi moi m'avait demandé
de faire une mission parlementaire donc
je rédige un rapport et c'est la gauche
qui vient me dire si tu écris ce que
nous sommes en train d'écrire ensemble
et qu'on en fait une proposition de loi
on l'accocine on faisait pas une loi
imber on faisait en réfléchissait à la
façon dont le monde avait évolué avec
une médecine très performante et qui
quelquefois
confinés à des situations qui étaient
insupportables pour le patient lui-même
ou pour sa famille et donc
c'était un peu une situation
prométhélène est-ce que Prométhée doit à
un moment donné la médecine doit pas
être prometteenne elle doit accepter
voilà excepté que la mort vienne et donc
on avait on a appelé ce rapport
d'ailleurs
respecter la vie et accepter la mort ce
qui était la recherche aussi de cet
équilibre
et puis bon on a écrit cette loi on a
écrit de manière maladroite ce texte il
est peut-être écrit maladroitement mais
il fait qu'on s'insus puisqu'il fait
qu'on s'insus à la fois auprès des
églises de l'Académie de médecine ou
encore même de la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en rappeler
les grands principes au fond ce texte il
est sur trois un triptyque le premier
c'est je t'abandonne jamais même si je
peux pas te guérir le deuxième c'est je
te laisserai pas souffrir et dans ce
texte il y avait un élément qui était
majeur je te laisserai pas souffrir même
si ça doit accélérer la mort donc
c'était libéré en fait je vais dire je
vais le caricaturer c'est libérer la
morphine en fin de vie on avait on avait
une situation il y a 20 ans où la
morphine c'était les dernières heures
alors que aujourd'hui vous voyez vous
sortez d'une opération on vous met de la
morphine on avait dans l'esprit une
perversion qui qui nous faisait croire
quand je dis nous c'est le corps médical
qui nous faisait croire que on allait
devenir toxicoman parce qu'on prenait de
la morphine sur des douleurs atroces et
et même et même si je veux dire quand
vous avez quelques jours à vivre
qu'est-ce que ça peut faire voilà et
donc on a imprimé dans ce texte que
en fin de vie la qualité de vie prime
sur la durée de la vie et enfin on a
défini ce qu'on appelle l'acharnement
thérapeutique ou plutôt l'obstination
des raisonnable on a dit que on pouvait
ne pas mettre en œuvre ou arrêter d'être
traitements qui étaient inutiles
disproportionnées faut-il faire une
chimiothérapie 3 jours avant que la
personne meurt en lui faisant subir une
violence et une souffrance
même si on gagne quelques heures ou même
quelques jours est-ce que ça vaut la
peine voilà et puis on a dit que on
pouvait arrêter des traitements
salvateurs de maintien en vie lorsque
ces traitements n'ont pas d'autres buts
que le maintien artificiel de la vie
c'est à dire ces situations végétatives
ou le cerveau est détruit le corps peut
continuer à vivre donc on peut
l'alimenter on peut faire respirer on
peut suppler les grandes fonctions de
l'organisme mais mais
avait-on le droit d'arrêter et très
honnêtement on le faisait vous-même en
tant que médecin réanimateur cardiologue
vous aviez eu à prendre ce type de
décision
oui le problème c'est que on prenait des
comme je le dis on prenait ces décisions
et on les prenait à la marge à la marge
de la loi et des règles médicales et au
fond on a on a dit c'est ça qui est bien
voilà à un moment donné si il faut
doubler la morphine parce que le malade
continue à souffrir doubler la morphine
ne lisez pas dans le Vidal que la dose
est toxique et je dirais et si la dose
est toxique
l'important c'est que la souffrance
disparaisse est-ce que cette loi elle
aurait permis de changer le sort de
Vincent Imbert oui oui
des lésions cérébrales majeures
irréversible il a quand même une vie qui
est dépendante de toute de la médecine
alors actuelle c'est mon fils était
encore vivant je n'aurais toujours pas
de solution pour lui parce que la loi
léonétique qui passe ce n'est que pour
les gens en fin de vie la loi est un
rare exemple de consensus politiques
parce qu'elle va être adoptée par
rassemblée à l'unanimité et dans la
foulée la loi va être adoptée en
première lecture et dans les mêmes
termes au Sénat pour la droite c'est une
forme d'aboutissement cette loi pour la
gauche c'est une étape et vous-même à
l'époque vous dites aller plus loin se
réaller ailleurs ailleurs c'est où c'est
l'euthanasie nous on a fait des lois
pour des gens qui vont mourir est-ce
qu'il faut faire une loi pour les gens
qui veulent mourir et si on fait une loi
pour les gens qui veulent mourir est-ce
qu'on a le droit de donner la mort or
donner la mort c'est pas dans le Code
civil et c'est pas dans le code de
déontologie donner la mort c'est dans le
code pénal voilà donc effet très
personnel vous étiez opposé ou favorable
à l'euthanasie non moi je suis opposé à
au fait de donner la mort non pas pour
des raisons religieuses parce qu'il y a
très peu de lois fondamentales il y a
une loi fondamentale une loi créance une
loi que vous avez le droit de réclamer à
la société c'est le droit à la vie
la loi leonétique 2005 a fait avancer
les choses mais elle a aussi fait des
déçus cela ne se contente pas d'un texte
qui permette aux médecins de laisser
mourir un malade incurable mais une
minute pour que celui-ci puisse l'aider
à mourir voir le faire mourir c'est une
différence majeure sur le plan éthique
médical et bien sûr juridique dans les
pays qui l'ont mis en place cette
liberté de choix traduite dans le droit
peut se décliner sous la forme
d'euthanasie ou de suicide assisté en
France un nouveau drame s'invite à la
une des journaux celui de Chantal Sebire
atteinte d'une tumeur très rare
incurable qui lui fait perdre
progressivement tous ses sens et
provoque des douleurs insupportables en
2008 elle demande au Président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy mais aussi à
la justice le droit à mourir dans la
dignité sans succès le 19 mars deux
jours après le rejet de sa demande par
le tribunal Chantal Sebire se suicide en
avalant des barbituriques l'affaire
divise une nouvelle fois la classe
politique et donne un argument
supplémentaire à une association qui
défend le droit pour chacun à une fin de
vie conforme à ses conceptions
personnelles l'Association pour le droit
à mourir dans la dignité passer son nom
trouve une oreille plus qu'attentive
chez plusieurs sénateurs de gauche comme
de droite monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues la loi
néonetti de 2005 a été une avancée
majeure dans le domaine de la fin de vie
et notamment pour les soins palliatifs
mais même si elle inscrit dans notre
arsenal juridique la raie à la vie elle
oublie de poser un supplément de choix
qui fait qu'une personne puisse décider
de mourir à son moment et selon ses
volontés bonjour l'infocher bonjour
Mathieu en 2008 vous êtes sénateur UMP
de la Vienne 6 mois après la mort de
Chantal Sebire vous allez déposer une
proposition de loi sur l'aide active à
mourir dans le respect des consciences
et des volontés nous sommes en 2008 soit
3 ans après la loi leonétique 2005 elle
ne vous satisfaisait pas cette loi
desonetti non parce que la loi
léodétique essentiellement tournée sur
les soins palliatifs on parlait à
l'époque de laisser mourir oui laissez
mourir c'est à dire que les gens au
dernier moment
on arrête les médicaments arrête les
traitements pas d'obstination
déraisonnable disait le texte de 2005
et vous voulez surtout pas d'aide active
à mourir c'était voilà cette loi a été
tout à fait insuffisante certains
disaient c'est une loi pour ceux qui
vont mourir et pas pour ceux qui veulent
mourir tu es loin pour ceux qui vont
mourir
ceux qui vont mourir mais dans la
souffrance parce que elle s'applique
vraiment au dernier moment et puis la
personne de contrôle pas elle-même sa
décision de mourir alors que la loi que
nous proposons c'est la personne qui
elle-même décide de sa vie de sa fin de
vie
cette proposition de loi que vous faites
en 2008 elle va rester de longs mois
dans des tiroirs jusqu'à ce que d'autres
sénateurs comme votre collègue
socialiste jean-Pierre Godefroy par
exemple ou le communiste Guy Fisher
dépose à leur tour des propositions de
loi qui vont dans le même sens et
qu'est-ce que vous allez décider
pour décider de se rencontrent et on
décide à la fois de se mettre ensemble
et en fait de joindre les textes les
textes aux joints il y a une proposition
de loi commune parce que les textes
étaient similaires
quasiment les mêmes c'est les mêmes
choses qu'on demande des uns les autres
avec les mêmes garanties au niveau
médical au niveau de la justice au
niveau de tout alors votre proposition
de loi elle comporte 8 articles elle
propose d'inscrire dans le code de la
santé publique que la personne malade a
droit au respect de sa liberté et de sa
dignité qu'elle peut bénéficier sous
certaines conditions d'une aide active à
mourir
vous vous êtes toujours refusé à
utiliser le mot deuthanasie pourquoi je
n'aime pas ce mot de ta nazi parce qu'il
rappelle des souvenirs affreux et
souvenir de la guerre les souvenirs des
nazis je pense que c'est pas le bon
terme euthanasie d'abord c'est tué c'est
la personne qui tue l'aide active à
mourir c'est la personne qui décide de
mourir en prenant un médicament souvent
un médicament les choses se passent
comme ça donc l'état d'Asie n'a jamais
été pour moi le bon mot à utiliser pour
ces raisons vous l'aviez faite pour le
symbole cette proposition de loi non j'y
croyais cette proposition de loi je l'ai
faite parce que j'ai pas envie de la
faire parce qu'il y a des gens qui
souhaitaient parce que dans mon
entourage beaucoup de gens
vivaient ces moments difficiles elle
souhaitait qu'une loi soit faite enfin
est-ce que vous sentiez isolé dans votre
propre camp quels étaient les réactions
de votre partie alors au niveau du parti
quand la reproduction de l'eau a été
déposée réunion de majorité UMP
il y a y a quelques amis qui m'ont dit
que votre la loi bon mais par contre au
niveau de du groupe MP
la discuté de ça en fin de séance et
puis on va dire non non comme ça ça a
été c'était ultra rapide
c'était tabou c'était c'était pas au
goût du jour des choses étaient aussi
avancés que maintenant voilà la raison
et puis il y avait beaucoup de gens
catholique conservateur aussi qui
voulait pas qu'on rentre là-dedans le 18
janvier 2011 le texte va passer en
commission des affaires sociales au
Sénat la commission des affaires
sociales qui étaient présidée par une
sautrice madame Dini
d'ailleurs cette grande surprise la
commission
vote alors il y avait j'ai vu quelques
personnes qui sautées au plafond c'était
c'est pas sûr commission l'examen de la
proposition de loi il est programmé pour
le 25 janvier oui mais voilà l'exécutif
ne va pas l'entendre de cette oreille et
François Fillon la veille des débats le
Premier ministre va publier une tribune
dans Le Monde pour s'élever contre votre
texte il dit que la question est de
savoir si la société est en mesure de
légiférer pour s'accorder le droit de
donner la mort j'estime que cette limite
ne doit pas être franchie est-ce qu'il
vous avait prévenu pas du tout
je n'ai pas eu un seul coup de fil de la
part du Premier ministre pas un seul
coup de fil de la part du ministre de la
Santé
pour me dire attention parce que j'étais
dans la même dans le dans la même
politique que pour me dire cher ami
attendez vous vous avez fait à peu près
de moi mais nous sommes pas d'accord
rien du tout et ils ont décidés
la date
de la session
tard le soir le 25 janvier au soir 22h
le soir ils ont prévu une heure et demie
pour un tas comme celui-ci alors que
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ça a duré des semaines et décèdes
l'espèce et des semaines ce texte on a
bâtir d'une heure et demi ça veut dire
que la batterie on a décidé pas de
discussion pas de débat on casse tous
les articles on supprime tous les
articles les uns après les autres c'est
ça pas de débat nous regrettons vivement
que ce débat qui va certainement se
dérouler bien au-delà de minuit et bien
puisse se faire dans ces conditions un
peu en catimini malheureusement nous
nous exprimons la nuit à 22h15 22h30 je
ne sais pas à quelle heure ces travaux
vont se terminer mais je trouve que sur
une question aussi importante et encore
une fois quel que soit le sentiment que
l'on peut avoir ce n'est pas
véritablement à la hauteur des enjeux ce
n'est pas digne de ce que nous voulons
faire ce n'est pas digne tout simplement
de ce que le Sénat et la Haute Assemblée
aujourd'hui merci monsieur le Président
de le transven il y a pas eu de débat
notamment parce que
le texte va être vidé de sa substance le
matin même le mardi 25 janvier au matin
la commission aux affaires sociales se
réunit il y a deux amendements qui sont
présentés deux amendements identiques
par deux sénatrices qui vide le texte de
sa substance
de toute façon il refusait tout débat ça
veut dire que c'était instrumentalisé
par l'exécutif
oui la commission des affaires sociales
se dégge à la commission
que la Commission des juges après avoir
voté pour parce qu'après il y a d'autres
gens qui sont dû renforcer la commission
après on arrête tout on peut pas dire
que ce soit un bon signe de démocratie
et de fonctionnement de l'institution
dans le 25 janvier au soir Xavier
Bertrand va rappeler dans l'hémicycle
l'opposition du gouvernement est-ce que
l'on souhaite
cesser un traitement maintenant un
patient en vie la situation aujourd'hui
où est-ce que l'on souhaite
autoriser un acte volontaire en vue
d'abréger la vie du patient
et nous sommes à un moment ce soir
où notre droit peut basculer
et pour ma part pour ma part je ne
souhaite pas que notre droit bascule
vous êtes déçu mais pas découragé
puisque l'année d'après vous redéposerez
une proposition de loi sur la tactile
elle viendra en son temps donc il faut
recommencer je veux qu'il y ait une
égalité sur le choix de la famille la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Muguette Dini plaide la cause
des défenseurs du libre choix de mourir
sans succès elle va dire ne vous arrosez
pas le droit de décider à la place de
ceux qui lucidement ont choisi le moment
de mettre fin à leur souffrance ne leur
volez pas leur ultime liberté pour vous
ce droit à mourir c'est une ultime
liberté c'est l'ultime liberté de
l'individu c'est sa liberté la personne
qui souffre qui a pas les moyens alors
Cabrel elle doit faire pour quitter la
vie de la dignité elle a plusieurs
possibilités effectivement se jeter du
dixième étage pour d'un fusil se faire
sauter la tête dans quel état on la
retrouve se pendre quand la famille
rentre le soir
donc il y a deux choses différentes il y
a les choses possibles
pour les gens riches les gens ils
partent entre eux en avion dans des
cliniques privées qui coûtent très cher
une souffrent plus et les gens qui sont
moins riches les familles vont les voir
souffrir et familles vont devoir
décliner et familles vont souffrir tout
le monde va souffrir la diode de la
justice incroyable et pour moi je dis il
faut qu'il y ait l'égalité dans ce sens
et le choix de la fin de vie doit être
le même pour tout le monde notre
responsabilité est de mieux répondre aux
souffrances c'est de protéger les
personnes vulnérables et non de donner
volontairement la mort à autrui c'est
ainsi à mon sens que nous répondrons de
la façon la plus juste et surtout la
plus digne au difficile débat sur la fin
de vie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
les partisans de l'aide active à mourir
ont donc perdu leur bataille mais déjà
ce profil à l'horizon la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 et il compte bien
en profiter pour imposer leur
revendication dans le débat François
Hollande a pris un engagement c'est
écrit noir sur blanc dans son programme
il veut permettre à toute personne
majeure en phase terminale d'une maladie
incurable de demander à bénéficier d'une
assistance médicalisée pour terminer sa
vie dans la dignité le 15 février 2012
François Hollande est en meeting à Rouen
et devant ses soutiens il rappelle sa
promesse claire sur le papier peut être
un peu moins clair à l'oral je
proposerai que toute personne
majeure en phase avancée ou terminale
incurable d'une maladie provoquant une
souffrance physique psychique
insupportable et qui que ne peut plus
être apaisé puisse demander dans des
conditions précises et sous contrôle de
plusieurs médecins à bénéficier d'une
assistance médicale pour vivre sa vie
dans
la dignité jusqu'à la fin
bonjour Michel meunier bonjour bravo
vous êtes sénatrice socialiste de
Loire-Atlantique depuis 2011 on vient
d'entendre François Hollande en meeting
dans sa campagne présidentielle 2012
qu'est-ce que vous aviez compris vous de
sa promesse sur la fin de vie pendant la
campagne moi j'avais compris que une
fois président François Hollande
mettrait en œuvre l'aide à mourir et
ainsi améliorer les conditions de fin de
vie on sent que François Hollande
lui-même a du mal à prononcer le mot
puisqu'il dit il y a un bénéfice d'une
assistance médicalisée pour vivre sa vie
jusqu'à la fin alors que dans le
programme il est écrit terminer sa vie
oui alors je prends ça pour un lapsus
j'ai peut-être tort mais dans son
programme c'était net c'était bien de ça
dont il s'agissait c'était terminé sa
vie de manière digne on a le sentiment
en début de son quinquennat que François
Hollande veut aller vite il confie un
premier rapport une première mission au
professeur Didier Sicard qui a été
l'ancien président du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique à charge pour lui de
lui remettre des préconisations ce que
fait Didier Sicard d'ailleurs six mois
plus tard on est en décembre 2012 et la
commission Sicard ne préconise pas
forcément un changement de loi mais
l'Élysée veut aller vite et lui promet
un projet de loi pour juin 2013 et puis
de précautions valent mieux qu'une
impression il va confier au Comité
consultatif national des tiques cette
fois aussi le soin d'apporter sa pierre
à l'édifice en demandant une
contribution un avis ce comité
consultatif national d'éthique vous vous
allez y être nommé quand vous arrivez
dans ce comité quels sont vos positions
sur la fin de vie moi je suis favorable
à l'aide active à mourir je pense que la
loi donne le cadre de liberté mais
qu'elle n'oblige personne à utiliser le
droit mais donnez le droit c'est prévoir
pour le plus grand nombre cette faculté
d'utiliser son droit et le la
précisément le droit à mourir dans la
dignité mais le Comité consultatif
national d'éthique dans lequel vous
rentrez vient de publier un avis à
l'époque défavorable à la dactive à
mourir il dit que ce serait un chemin
dangereux à suivre alors les avis du
Conseil national d'éthique comme tous
les avis qui ont suivi sont toujours
très balancés et là dans cet avis quand
vous regardez bien il est globalement
défavorable à aller plus loin mais il a
une annexe un rajout une contribution
dont je suis signataire qui dit que il
faut s'interroger pour donner plus de
possibilités et de facultés et de droit
aux personnes
concernés vous c'est une conviction que
vous êtes forgé au fil de votre
existence où vous avez connu peut-être
des événements personnels qui vous ont
confrontés à la fin de vie à cette
époque là je ne dis pas concernée du
tout par
la fin de vie donc c'est une conviction
politique et sociétale politique que je
prends davantage pour moi depuis la
crise sanitaire bien sûr où j'ai vu mes
deux parents décédés dans des conditions
qu'il n'aurait pas souhaité François
Hollande avait annoncé je le disais tout
à l'heure un projet de loi pour l'été
2013 mais l'affaire prend beaucoup
beaucoup de retard à l'été 2014 le
Premier ministre Manuel Valls confie une
mission encore une j'ai envie de dire à
deux députés le socialiste Alain classe
et revoilà Jean Leonetti ils vont lui
remettre des conclusions en décembre
pourquoi cette course de lenteur
pourquoi une commission puis de un
nouveau la vie puis une nouvelle mission
comment vous expliquer ça
moi je l'explique par le contexte
politique
donc connaissez la France avec d'autres
sujets de société il y avait un sujet de
société majeur qui avait fracturé
l'opinion publique et les Français c'est
le mariage pour tous c'est ça qu'on
voulait parler tout à fait et cette
année
2013 on était encore dedans on était
encore
à cicatrisation qui avait pas eu lieu
enfin c'est une fracture franchement
vous vous voulez dire c'est que François
Hollande avait peur d'une certaine façon
enfin l'exécutif avait peur de
refracturer la France avec le sujet sur
la fin de vie François Hollande ne
voulait pas refacturer la France et il
cherchait à tout prix un équilibre un
consensus sur cette question et c'est ce
qui je pense a motivé
ces différentes commissions
consultatives c'est ces expertises des
propositions de loi aussi qui sont
arrivées de tous les côtés mais
d'écouter socialistes aussi pour
essayer de débloquer de débloquer les
choses mais dans une douceur enfin
sans déchirer c'est pour ça qu'on va
rechercher Jean Leonetti je pense je
pense qu'on va chercher à la droite et à
la gauche de cette question alors quand
je dis droite gauche ça veut dire les
deux positions peut-être antagonistes
sur cette question là effectivement j'ai
reçu une lettre de mission que j'ai
acceptée de la part du président
et sa date de mission elle est tout à
fait différente donc de la première loi
puisque là on est dans une loi sur
commande du président de la République à
partir d'un rapport qui est le rapport
si car qui dit en gros on écoute pas
assez les malades et on meurt mal en
France encore malgré la loi de 2005 et
donc on part sur cette base j'ai pas
fixé des limites mais j'ai dit très
sincèrement au président de la
République que s'il y avait une aide
active à mourir il fallait pas venir me
chercher moi il fallait en chercher un
autre voilà parce que
à ce moment là et c'était pourtant sa
promesse
non c'est pas sa promesse il faut lire
avec
le président Hollande est un homme
subtil et intelligent et il a jamais dit
que la promesse était le zanazi alors
cette proposition de loi elle va voir le
jour elle va être consignée par Alain
Cleis et Jean Leonetti et puis elle
prévoit dans certains cas un recours à
ce qu'on appelle une sédation profonde
et continue jusqu'au décès mais ne parle
pas d'euthanasie ni de suicide assisté
vous êtes déçu à l'époque
disons que oui je franchement je suis
déçu parce que la sédation profonde est
continue on peut la prendre comme une
aide de passive mais ça ne vient pas
remplacer une aide active à mourir j'ai
l'intime conviction qu'il faut permettre
aux personnes atteintes d'une maladie
grave et incurable entraînant une
souffrance physique ou psychique
insupportable de mourir dans la dignité
il s'agit dès lors de passer dans les
cas de figures précis strictes et
encadré lui laisser mourir à l'aide à
mourir parce que la commission des
affaires sociales au Sénat où vous siégé
à l'époque
va complètement détricoter le texte
class Leonetti c'est un coût politique
où il y a quelque chose de plus profond
qui s'exprime je pense pas que ce soit
un coup politique c'est c'est
idéologiquement contre les valeurs de la
droite c'est du conservatif c'est
peut-être une influence religieuse
c'est pour moi le faire religieux qui
fait tout ça parce que
l'idée que même un médecin ne peut pas
toucher à
l'oeuvre de Dieu c'est quand même
quelque part
dérangeant enfin moi je suis pas du tout
dans cette conception là je suis pour
des valeurs laïques mon sentiment c'est
que c'est ça qui se joue c'est c'est le
fait religieux qui prend qui prend part
sur le cadre législatif est-ce que vous
pensez que la gauche a loupé un coche
qu'elle a raté une occasion à l'époque
je pense qu'on n'a pas été à l'époque
jusqu'à nos engagements programmatiques
et que dans nos engagements
programmatifs il y avait une aide active
à mourir mais à trop
faire de consultation de débats de
recherche
on permet encore une fois aux
oppositions de ce cristalliser et de
s'organiser la loi classe Leonetti est
adoptée en première lecture après des
débats apaisés à l'Assemblée nationale
par une très grande majorité 436 voix
pour 34 contre et 82 abstentions mais si
la recherche du consensus domine à
l'Assemblée une fois n'est pas coutume
ici au Sénat c'est une autre paire de
manches certains considèrent que cette
nouvelle loi n'est pas le prolongement
nécessaire de la précédente mais une
véritable rupture éthique et politique
donner un cas de législatif approprié au
dernier moment relève du défi volton des
moments de vie de partage et d'échanges
avec les proches quand la science est
devenue impuissante à soulager que
l'heure de la mort a sonné
porte-t-on atteinte à la vie en
accordant dans les derniers moments le
repos qui apaise allège les souffrances
et les tourments la proposition de loi
de nos collègues députés à l'inclès et
Jean léonity et critiqué par ceux qui
craignent que les évolutions successives
du droit ne poussent les personnes en
fin de vie à considérer que leur
existence est une charge pour les autres
mais aussi par ceux pour qui la vie
relève du sacré elle n'est pas moins
critiquée par ceux qui réclament le
droit à une assistance médicalisée pour
mourir ou au suicide assisté c'est
pourquoi dans l'examen de ce texte
nous devons faire preuve à la fois
d'humilité et d'humanité humilité car
nous nous sentons pas le droit de porter
un jugement sur l'utilité de la vie
Fustel dans sa phase
ultime quand une main serrée à sourire
donnée permettent au mourant d'affronter
le dernier passage
bonjour Vous ne Retailleau bonjour à
vous vous êtes sénateurs de Vendée
aujourd'hui président du groupe LR au
Sénat et en 2015 vous allez prendre la
tête de la fronde contre la loi kless
Leonetti certains expliquent à l'époque
qu'elle complète la première loi de 2005
vous vous y voyez une vraie rupture
pourquoi
on est donc en 2015 et 2016 c'est-à-dire
quelques années après que la première
loi les néoptique a été évoquée en 2005
avec un vote à l'unanimité et sur la fin
de vie sur des choses qui sont aussi
délicates où on a les uns et les autres
et appréhensions très différentes parce
que il y a un rapport à la vie un
rapport à la souffrance il y a des
expériences personnelles aussi qui
peuvent entrer en jeu mais je
considérais que ça n'était pas si j'ose
dire raisonnable de légiférer à 10 ans
près il y avait eu une anémie ce qui est
tellement rare une unanimité dans ces
questions sociétales qu'il fallait
essayer de préserver cette unité j'étais
particulièrement choquée pas que moi par
l'article 3 de ce texte l'article 3
parlait de la prolongement d'une vie
inutile
qui peut s'arroger le droit
de dire qu'une vie est devenue
inutile ça me paraissait à l'époque une
rupture y compris anthropologique
extrêmement profonde on a voulu être des
lanceurs d'alerte on a réussi à gagner
parce que en commission mixte paritaire
l'article 3 a été supprimé vous avez à
la fin on a tous vécu avec des parents
proches des derniers instants et je
crois que dans ces instants là il peut y
avoir des mots qui disent tout et des
gestes qui sauvent tout
d'un père avec son fils ou inversement
il y a un autre article qui va
concentrer une grande partie des
critiques c'est celui qui prévoit une
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès le texte commence par à la demande
du malade et elle a du monde du malade
dans des circonstances qui sont établies
bien sûr il faut que le malade souffre
voilà et il faut que ça fait un devis
soit pas trop éloigné mais elle a le
droit de dormir il a le droit de dormir
pour ne pas souffrir avant de mourir là
aussi on a dit c'est ambigu non c'est
pas ambigu les médicaments qu'on prend
pour dormir c'est pas les mêmes
médicaments qu'on prend pour tuer et
dans le le fait de dire vous avez le
droit de vous endormir
et la mort viendra vous prendre dans
votre sommeil c'est un élément fortement
apaisant sécurisant cette sédation est
beaucoup plus qu'un geste palliatif
est-ce que ce droit sera un droit à
dormir avant de mourir
est-ce que ce droit sera
un droit d'endormir pour faire mourir
est-ce que ce droit sera un moyen de
soulager
de consistait pas dans ces objectifs à
donner la mort mais consistait bien à
soulager de la souffrance que ce
soulagement de la souffrance hâte la
mort c'est possible mais ça n'était pas
l'objectif premier recherche il y a un
autre point qui est cristallise les
débats il concernait ce qu'on appelle
les directives anticipées la loi
prévoyait de les rendre contraignantes
c'est à dire qu'elle s'impose au médecin
et ça ça vous inquiétait aussi et on a
voulu s'assurer que auprès des soignants
on a voulu relayer aussi cet avis de
soignants pour qu'ils soient pas
instrumentalisé prise en otage et
conduit à exécuter des actes c'est à
dire à administrer une mort médicale si
j'ose dire contre leur gré alors il y a
la clause de conscience bien sûr est-ce
que le fait que cette loi soit portée
sous un président de gauche et voter à
l'assemblée par une majorité de gauche à
jouer c'est ce que pense par exemple
Jean Leonetti le Sénat d'abord il voit
il voit une deuxième loi alors que
alors qu'ils pensent que la première loi
est suffisante
et la première loi elle vient
elle vient d'un groupe qui est le sien
donc au fond on enlève sa loi pour faire
une note loi cette autre loi est pardon
de ces caricatures mais elles existent
aussi cette autre loi elle est quand
même
programmée
par le Président de la République qui
est socialiste c'est pas des forcément
des clients partisans c'est des
méfiances légitimes voilà ce qui me
vient de l'adversaire dans la politique
en général c'est dommage mais c'est
ainsi a priori je m'en méfie voilà
sans doute que ça peut jouer sans doute
que ça a pu jouer c'est toujours la
question des lois sociétales vous savez
quand un président aujourd'hui a du mal
à réformer sur l'aspect économique ou
social il trouve toujours une bonne loi
sociétale il a les médias avec lui le
pilon public ça coûte pas cher et ça
permet si on se dire de cocher la case
du progressisme
différentes choses ça peut jouer très
honnêtement cette ça n'est pas ce qui a
joué en premier lieu au Sénat en tout
cas pour mon groupe et pour moi-même on
a voulu une fois de plus vérifier qu'on
ne franchissait pas des seuils
anthropologiques qui soient des vraies
ruptures en plus
à l'époque on se lamentait et
aujourd'hui c'est terrible parce que la
première loi Léonetti avait bien posé un
principe de développement des soins
palliatifs et aujourd'hui encore au
moment où je vous parle et c'était pire
il y a quelques années il y a encore 26
départements qui n'ont pas d'unité de
soins palliatifs
l'enseignement pour les les étudiants de
médecine sur les notions de souffrance
de douleur sur les soins palliatifs et
très résiduel c'est pas normal
aujourd'hui qui est plus de 150 000
Français qui ne puissent pas avoir accès
aux soins palliatifs attention à ce que
par des lois on ne tente pas de régler
des problèmes qui supposeraient qu'on
est mis sur la table plus de moyens
notamment pour faire en sorte de
soulager la souffrance des Français qui
parviennent au crépuscule de leur vie
comment vous tenez compte de la liberté
individuelle de notre de l'autre côté
les gens qui disent ben c'est mon choix
qu'on ne s'acharne pas c'est mon choix
de partir maintenant c'est mon choix de
de choisir l'instant de ma mort
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle
Ernst hello disait un jour au bout du
compte tout le monde s'assoit au banquet
des conséquences ce que il voulait dire
c'est que dans une loi sociétale et on
le voit au Canada on le voit en Hollande
on le voit aussi en Belgique qui ont
autorisé le Tani au départ vous
commencez tout doucement vous proclamez
un droit notamment pour ceux qui
arrivent en fin de vie mais à chaque
fois on enclenche après
immuablement d'autres étapes qui parfois
peuvent conduire au pire quelqu'un que
je lisais il y a quelques semaines
qui est un médecin hollandais qui a
beaucoup fait pour l'euthanasie
justement au Pays-Bas
déplorer le fait que aujourd'hui
désormais il y a à peu près les deux
tiers qui sont vraiment en fin de vie
qui sont euthanasiés alors qu'au départ
c'était 88% et que de moins en moins en
réalité le tanasie va concerner des
personnes en fin de vie et c'est ces
questions qu'on doit poser résultat du
scrutin 215 sur l'ensemble de la
promotion de loi créant de nouveaux
droits pour les personnes malades en fin
de vie compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote nombre de votants
339 nombre de suffrages exprimés 283
pour l'adoption 87 contre 196 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour Claire Touri bonjour vous êtes
membre du Conseil économique social et
environnemental et vingt ans après
l'affaire Humbert se débat sur la fin de
vie j'ai envie de dire qu'il rebondit un
peu avec vous aujourd'hui puisque vous
êtes présidé le comité de gouvernance de
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie mise en place par le Président de la
République
on a envie de dire une commission de
plus non est-ce que tout n'a pas été dit
la question alors je crois pas que tout
était dit il y a un débat national sur
la fin de vie qui a commencé si on doit
le marquer avec la vie du CCNE le Comité
consultatif national d'éthique qui rend
son avis en septembre et qui pour la
première fois ouvre une porte pour une
éventuelle aide active à mourir dans
certaines conditions mais une fois qu'on
a dit ça on n'a rien dit en réalité et
quand on va un cran plus loin on se rend
compte qu'il y a tout un tas de
situations qui sont complexes qui
nécessite d'aller un peu dans la nuance
de d'aller un cran en dessous dans la
granularité et faire ça c'est pas des
sondages qui le permettent aujourd'hui à
185 citoyens qui ont été tirés au sort
qui sont membres de cette convention
citoyenne sur la qui a commencé ses
travaux le 9 décembre qu'ils a terminé
le 2 avril et qui est chargé d'éclairer
justement la décision publique du point
de vue citoyen sur la question de la fin
de vie quelle était la feuille de route
que vous avez fixée l'exécutif le cadre
d'accompagnement est-il adapté
d'éventuels changements devraient-ils
être introduit et c'est comme ça qu'on a
organisé la réponse à la question autour
de ce qu'on appelle des nœuds de débat
donc il y a la partie consensuelle ce
qui voilà ce vers quoi tous les citoyens
tendent donc le renforcement par exemple
des soins palliatifs le la formation
l'information les moyens la recherche le
développement enfin vraiment toutes ces
propositions qu'on appelle le quoi qu'il
en soit quel que soit notre avis sur
l'aide active à mourir il faut investir
massivement sur ces grandes thématiques
et ensuite il y a les noeuds de débat
donc autour de la dactive à mourir
est-ce qu'on est pour ou contre une
adaptive à mourir et une fois qu'on a
répondu à cette question laquelle pour
qui comment à quelles conditions ils ont
rencontré des experts ils ont rencontré
des grands témoins oui ils rencontrer
des soignants ils ont rencontré des
patients ils ont rencontré les cultes
ils ont rencontré les obéiances
maçonniques ils ont rencontré Alain
clesses qui est venu présenter la
dernière loi Jean Leonetti n'était
malheureusement pas disponible mais à
l'inclès l'a fait et vous avez le
sentiment que tous ces entretiens ont
changé leur perception de ce dossier sur
la fin de vie oui je crois oui en fait
je crois que c'est un vrai cheminement
collectif la dactive à mourir c'est pas
juste qu'on oui ou non en fait c'est on
peut être contre et en même temps à
certains moments se dire que bah on est
contre mais il y a des situations qui
sont intolérables on peut être pour mais
se dire qu'on peut être pour à certaines
conditions bien précises ou alors on
peut se dire qu'on est pour a priori de
manière théorique et puis une fois qu'on
entend des témoignages se dire que bon
bah peut-être qu'en fait c'est pas si
simple oui la parole du soignant elle
compte et elle il faut la prendre en
compte où on peut être contre mais quand
on entend un militant de l'ADMD de
l'Association pour le droit à mourir
dans la dignité expliquer que après tout
pourquoi est-ce que on serait contre si
les soins palliatifs sont développés ben
voilà on peut nuancer son point de vue
et c'est pour ça que 27 jours de le
travail c'est pas trop pour faire pour
faire cheminer 185 citoyens et après
tous ces débats ils se sont prononcés
très majoritairement pour un changement
de la loi il y a une majorité très forte
qui se prononce en faveur d'une aide
activée
oui participants se prononce pour une
aide active à mourir mais il y a 25% qui
sont contre donc moi je dirais pas que
c'est un consensus c'est il y a une
tendance forte pour une adaptive à
mourir il y a une partie de ce collectif
qui qui n'est pas favorable et c'est
aussi ça qui est intéressant dans la
réponse qui a été apportée par les
citoyens c'est pas une réponse
consensuelle ça c'est très important de
le dire c'est pas il n'y a pas c'est pas
c'est pas une réponse qui noie le
dissensus c'est une réponse qui pose la
controverse et les participants à la
Convention ils se sont exprimés plutôt
favorablement pour le suicide assisté un
peu moins pour l'euthanasie
surtout en faveur du suicide assisté
ce qui est pas très surprenant en
réalité puisque le sud assisté ça veut
dire qu'on
qu'on s'injecte soi-même le produit
enfin c'est un peu réducteur de dire ça
comme ça l'euthanasie ça implique qui
l'intervention de quelqu'un d'autre donc
forcément ça pose d'autres questions que
que qui peut interroger certains membres
de la Convention est-ce que d'une
certaine manière c'est pas une défaite
du politique
de montrer que il y a eu deux lois et
que les parlementaires la classe
politique est pas forcément capable
d'aller au-delà et donc du coup on s'en
remet un nouveau système je sais pas si
c'est une défaite moi je pense que c'est
plutôt une marque d'intelligence du
politique de dire qu'il y a certains
moments où il faut faire un pas de côté
il faut organiser des espaces créer des
espaces comme comme les conventions
citoyennes mais sur la fin de vie comme
sur d'autres sujets ou on accepte
pendant un temps de voilà de de voir la
décision se construire ailleurs
autrement les politiques à la fin ils
prennent les décisions ils ont été élus
pour ça ils ont cette responsabilité et
personne la conteste en tout cas pas
dans cette convention citoyenne par
contre pour reprendre les propos du
président du CESU si la décision à la
partie aux élus la construction de la
décision l'appartient à tout le monde
vous attendez quoi des parlementaires
aujourd'hui qu'isaillent au bout du
débat j'attends qu'ils aillent au bout
du débat qui qui tiennent compte de ce
que les citoyens vont produire ça veut
pas dire qu'il y a du enfin je sais
qu'il y a pas de sans filtre les
conditions ont été très claires mais
entre le sans filtre du tout il y a
quand même beaucoup de choses au milieu
et donc demander à des citoyens de
bosser pendant 27 jours de leur vie
quand même c'est énorme le rythme entre
eux pendant quatre mois sur un sujet
aussi difficile que celui de la fin de
vie et ne rien en faire du tout
considéré que c'est un gadget
franchement moi je suis pas élu de la
République mais si je l'étais je me
poserai un peu la question avant de
balayer ça d'un revers de main en
sachant le niveau de défiance que nos
concitoyens on vis-à-vis nos
institutions il y a des vrais un vrai
danger à mes yeux à ouvrir la porte
d'une législation qui pourrait donner la
mort à quelqu'un qui l'a demande la mort
fait partie de la vie et bien mourir
c'est avoir une belle vie je vous dis
à Paris que cette loi sera votée à plus
ou moins long terme elle sera voté parce
que les mentalités progressent et les
jours ne supportent plus la souffrance
je sais parfaitement que dès lors qu'on
aura autorisé le suicide assisté on
autorisera ensuite le tanaisie c'est
simplement une question de les lois
Leonetti et classes Leonetti ont
incontestablement fait avancer les
droits des malades et ont offert un
cadre éthique et juridique au médecin
autrefois bien souvent livré leur
conscience dans le secret des chambres
des malades peut-on aller plus loin en
garantissant à chacun d'entre nous une
ultime liberté de choix le regard que
porte la société sur la fin de vie à
changer ce qui était jugé impensable ou
dangereux hier et devenu pour beaucoup
nécessaire ou même souhaitable mais la
difficulté on l'a vu dans cette émission
consiste à fixer des règles générales
simples qui s'appliquent à des
situations personnelles complexes tout
en respectant bien sûr les grands
principes qui font de notre République
et qui régissent notre vie en société
une chose est sûre cette ultime liberté
de choix elle mérite mieux que des
affrontements et des anathèmes elle
mérite un débat serein un travail
minutieux un vote courageux une mission
dont les législateurs se sont toujours
montrés capables chaque fois qu'il s'éti
de répondre à une demande de la société
par une grande loi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
magazine historia vous a présenté il
était une loi quand le Sénat écrit
l'histoire